[Musique]
beaucoup trop d'énergie alors il faut
aussi peut-être revenir à des à des
méthodes de bon sens il parle de
méthodes frugales vous voulez des
exemples ou des exemples
on y va alors par exemple et bien des
muséologique en fait sont des tissus
techniques qui sont évidemment des
reconstitutions de titiosa mais
intrinsèquement fabriqué de sorte à
éviter les effets nocifs du soleil une
trop grande lumière etc après vous avez
aussi des trous de buée alors ça c'est
surtout au Portugal m'a dit Danielo
forleo mais il y en a aussi quelques
fois sur les fenêtres du château c'est
en fait pour éviter la condensation
il y a un petit trou l'eau s'écoule
gentiment et après ne va pas sur une
rainure et ne va pas aller abîmer les
boiseries de la fenêtre par exemple mais
alors on sait très bien mais ça peut
aussi envoyer de l'air trop froid ou
trop chaud alors enfin c'est très très
délicat très minutieux donc il travaille
en corrélation avec le réseau des
résidences royales européennes donc là
il s'échangent les informations tout un
tas de statistiques pour mettre en place
d'une méthodologie efficace ils ont
travaillé avec Turin et avec la Pologne
là de chance ça va être le château de
Chantilly et le Palais Princier de
Monaco voilà
il faut regarder les symptômes donc en
fait la chaleur fait que il y a des
insectes qui s'installent dans les
boiseries de la moisissure
on croit que qu'il y ait trop de public
c'est mauvais mais finalement ça peut
brasser l'air et ça permet d'éviter les
moisissures il y a tout un tas de
paramètres à prendre en compte et à
analyser pour après
pondre une belle charte 2025 qui servira
à tous les châteaux musées et
collections d'Europe
transition énergétique aussi
technologique d'ailleurs vous êtes très
technologies ce soir Véronique à la
pointe de l'actualité du futur et vous
allez nous parler maintenant d'une
startup qui a inventé des nouvelles
plantes génétiquement de modifiées qui
purifient l'air c'est quoi le nom de
cette plante elle s'appelle cette
start-up elle a été très très aidée par
la Région Île-de-France ils se sont deux
deux chercheurs qui s'appellent Lionel
Morat et Patrick Orbec qui ont eu cette
idée géniale
ils ont été ils ont profité des
infrastructures des laboratoires de
Saclay d'accord et puis de bref tout ce
qui est là bas et ils ont trouvé alors
il s'appelle potos cette plante quand
vous tapez vous verrez c'est une bande
que tout le monde connaît elle est très
très commune alors évidemment ils lui
ont modifié son il est aux modifié l'ADN
pour qu'elle puisse capter le CO2 et les
quatre principaux polluants de l'ère
intérieur imaginez-vous parce que c'est
pour purifier l'air intérieur et jusqu'à
présent il y a déjà des plantes qui
existent mais qui se passent super
efficaces celle-ci elle va être vraiment
du tonnerre de Dieu mais alors le seul
truc c'est que bon ça y est elle est
elle est elle est conçue si je puis dire
mais en France on est soumis à la
Constitution européenne pour avoir un
agrément pour vendre un produit donc ils
pourront la développer en France que de
trop dans trois ans et demi ou 4 ans le
temps d'avoir l'agrément européen parce
que c'est c'est aussi une question de
vote c'est pas que scientifique alors
qu'en revanche aux États-Unis c'est
juste scientifique ils prennent ils
prennent pas c'est donc là ils vont
justement commercialiser aux États-Unis
pour démarrer puisque ils ont beau être
à Saint-Ouen avoir laboratoire à
Saint-Ouen être prêt et tout ils peuvent
pas se permettre d'attendre quatre ans
avant de vendre ce produit voilà donc
cette plante elle est absolument
incroyablement géniale et c'est pas très
scientifique de dire c'est un mais c'est
pas grave et eux ils veulent après
travailler encore plus largement sur la
qualité de l'air et le climat sortir un
peu de l'intérieur mais déjà si on
dépollue l'intérieur c'est extra c'est
déjà extra on prend les agendas pour
pour terminer avec une avant-première ça
se passe jeudi prochain oui c'est
bientôt c'est jeudi à 20h30 au Cyrano à
Versailles alors vous connaissez que
Xavier de Lausanne vous allez connaître
c'est
un documentariste très talentueux comme
moi j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer pour
deux VIP c'était les enfants valises et
après je l'ai reçu pour
neuf jours à RACA documentaire sur une
jeune femme Lila Mustapha qui était la
première mère de de j'ai envie
elle était la mère de racaille sa
mission c'était pas très compliqué
c'était reconstruire la ville donc elle
a réussi à imposer son autorité et dans
ce monde d'homme donc ça en fait c'est
une trilogie sur la vie après daesh qui
a entrepris de filmer Xavier de Lausanne
donc 9 jours à RACA cet effet s'est fait
en 21 et là sort cette fameuse
avant-première en toute liberté une
virgule une radio pour la paix vous avez
donc je dis demain ça 20h30 il y a une
présentation avec Xavier de Lausanne le
réalisateur et il reste après le film
n'est pas très long un peu plus d'une
heure et il reste après pour un débat et
alors Xavier de Lausanne il a filmé 7
jeunes journalistes qui sont aussi bien
musulmans chrétiens que yezidy et qui
vont tendre leur micro
aux gens qui veulent la paix c'est
vraiment donner la parole on va regarder
un extrait de la bande-annonce d'accord
comme ça on se fait une idée du film
[Musique]
à ceux qui veulent la paix
et voilà donc ça c'est le deuxième film
de la trilogie et le troisième sortira
bien sûr après bientôt ça s'appelle
Mossoul campus ce sera à propos de
d'étudiants à la Bibliothèque
Universitaire de Mossoul qui se sort de
forum pour parler de leurs rêves de
leurs histoires enfin voilà et le don
qu'a Xavier de Lausanne c'est toujours
de parler de petits miracles d'humanité
qu'il va déceler comme ça dans des dans
des
situations très chaotiques et très très
compliquée et ça date de l'histoire que
c'est beau et intéressant voilà première
ce jeudi du côté du cinéma Le cyano à
Versailles il y a une information qui a
obtenu plus votre attention qu'une autre
les plantes peut-être
le potos développé par cette startup
française
on l'espère de voir le projet émerger en
Europe merci Véronique en tout cas pour
pour ces idées insolites et on se
retrouve dans deux semaines pour les
prochaines pour les prochaines vidéos
insolites autour du département des y